you've said that a marriage must be
based on trust and transparency and
being shackled together how and for how
long should you get to know someone how
to set a foundation oh well you know
there's no there's no simple answer to
that I think that you should know
someone well enough so that you can so
that you know if you can negotiate with
them and so that you have started to
formulate a vision of your joint future
that you can both look forward to with
enthusiasm and confidence so and of
course that's going to depend to some
degree on your level of maturity but
that means you've considered such things
as do you have a sufficient number of
joint interests and are you oriented in
the same direction with regards to how
you're going to handle your joint
careers and the possibility of children
and the the manner in which you're going
to interact with your in-laws and you
have to start thinking about you have to
start considering your life together
from the perspective of practicality and
economics I would say so it can't just
be that
massive erotic attraction that's
associated with with love although I
think that's extraordinarily important
and you're unbelievably fortunate if you
have that and you should do everything
you can to maintain it which and that
takes effort that takes real effort and
will but you need to allow that with
with maturity and intelligence and the
maturity and intelligence is okay we're
going to put our lives together what's
that going to look like at the level of
detail how are we going to handle our
finances where are we going to live what
are our joint plans going to be et
cetera one of the things that my
business partners and I plan to do in in
what would you say that in as an analog
to the self authoring suite is that we
want to develop an online program to
help people negotiate their
relationships and and so it would
actually provide an answer
to this question in a more comprehensive
manner is it imagine that if you want to
set up a household with someone then
there's a lot of things that you need to
get straight and you either do that by
bringing your unconscious assumptions to
bear on the situation and perhaps
clashing where they don't match or you
sit down like a conscious and aware and
articulate couple and start to negotiate
what your joint responsibilities are
going to be and so that would be well
who's responsible for the meals and when
and what are you going to eat and who's
going to get groceries and who's going
to pay the bills and who's going to do
which part of what household chores
there are to do and how is that going to
be laid out fair and so you should get
to know you should get to know the
person that you're with well enough so
that you can start discussing the real
practical issues of life and determine
whether or not you're capable of
negotiating that and I don't think that
necessarily means that you should live
together because the evidence is
actually quite strong at least the last
time I looked at people who live
together are more rather than less
likely to be divorced now that might be
that might have nothing to do with the
actual act of living together it might
be that people who are more likely to
get divorced or also those who are more
likely to merely live together but I
don't think that's a great solution for
reasons I won't get into now and with
regards to being shackled together is
that that's a complicated one and and I
learned this at least in part from
reading Carl Jung and the idea there is
that unless you've really made a
commitment to someone like a lifetime
commitment and that that's a serious
commitment one that you're not going to
back out of you're not going to take the
relationship with the seriousness that's
necessary to make it of the highest
possible quality and sustainability
across the course of your life and it's
really important that it is of that high
quality and sustainability because the
relationship especially when it starts
to produce children is a machine let's
say a machine that you jointly operate
that adds immensely to the quality of
your life and the depth of your life I
mean you you have the rope and strand of
your life and your partner has the
strands in the row
of his or her life and then those are
tied together to make a stronger rope
and then that unites you across time and
then you undertake massive adventures
together and some of that is the
establishment of a household and the
establishment of joint careers and the
maintenance of each other's mental and
physical health and the maintenance of a
high quality sexual life and all of that
very very challenging to do all of that
and then the joint production end and
care of children which which sets you up
properly for the last half of your life
so like I'm 55 now you know and both my
kids just got engaged in the last month
so that's pretty bloody amazing and
they're both setting up households and
and they're stepping into adulthood and
I'm fortunate enough to have them in the
city that I live in so hooray for me
that's so bloody fortunate that I can
hardly believe it I mean we've helped
them out and tried to make it what would
you say to make the possibility of their
living here be something that's viable
but I'm absolutely thrilled that they're
going to be around and I'm looking
forward immensely to having
grandchildren and like what else are you
going to do when you're 55 you know and
you're going to be 55 it's going to I
might have 40 more years like what am I
going to do with those years well so I
have a good marriage thank God for that
and that's partly due to the outstanding
moral quality of my life my wife who I'm
also extraordinarily attracted to and
you know we built a life together and
we've had kids together and we're happy
with our kids and we had plenty of
struggle with our kids because one of
our children my daughter had serious
serious health problems which she seems
to have managed to resolve partly as a
consequence of her own brilliance but
you know we've set ourselves up now so
that our children are respectable and
mature young adults so thank God for
that and they've got partners who we
both really like and they're going to
have children and well hooray you know
that means that this next part of my
life is going to be something that I can
advance into with a with a fair bit of
hope and and excitement and the idea of
having little kids around again is
thrilling because I really like little
kids they're really really fun and so
there's the
tackle together is more like it it's
it's it's such a I may have even said
that but it's such a cynical way of
looking at it it's more like what you've
produced is an unbreakable bond between
two beings and that that makes both of
them both of them better in every way if
it's based on if it's a relationship
that's based on trust and genuine
communication it's very difficult thing
to attain because you have to be willing
to tell the truth and the truth is DARAB
generally a horrible thing you know I
mean it's easy to tell truth when
everyone wants to hear what you have to
say but it's very difficult to tell the
truth when no one wants to hear it least
of all yourself and so marriage gets a
very bad rap in our culture and so does
child rearing and I think that's
absolute catastrophe because really
being in a long-term relationship a
marriage let's say and having children
that's two-thirds of your life even if
you're a highly career oriented person
that's two thirds of your life and I'm a
highly career oriented person and my
family has been unbelievably important
to me and has also been something that's
enabled me to be very effective in my
career because my house has been a
sanctuary for me and thank God for that
especially over many times in my life
especially over the last year so you
should you should get to know someone
long enough to know that you too can
tell the truth with each other
communicate and negotiate because the
most important part of a relationship is
the fact that you can tell each other
the truth and negotiate